My name is Jess Holtz. I'm a technician
at Boston University, but also an artist.
I've been doing these micro-landscapes for a
while now, and these are microsculptures. They're
made out of insects and plants. And you can see
there's a flower and a fern in front of this one.
And my imaging technology of choice
is the Scanning Electron Microscope,
but I tilt the stage of the electron
microscope such that you're seeing it
kind of straight on instead of looking
from the top. So this is what they look
like before they go into the SEM. And this
is the one we're going to look at today,
a bunch of mostly plants but a few insect parts.
I have loaded it into this instrument, Hitachi
desktop SEM. Take a good look at it, because
it's going to look very different on the SEM.
Okay so what we're starting with
is a hydrangea flower that has been sort
of eaten and we can zoom in quite a bit.
We're at 25 times magnification. Let's start
moving around. Down here we've got a leaf and it's
covered with these trichromes which is like, if
you see the fuzz on a leaf this is what the fuzz
looks like, although it can look sometimes they're
like branched sometimes they're very different.
Okay so this is a bug, obviously.
We can look at the compound eyes.
So yeah, insect eyes are covered with these
ommatidia that are little lens lids that
give you to the image being formed. Down here we
have an insect leg covered in these sensory hairs
kind of like whiskers. Keep moving.
This is a plant, I'm not sure
what type but it's pretty cool.
These really interesting little like
tentacle-like things most likely trichromes.
Keep moving. Another leaf covered in trichomes.
It's kind of shriveled, and there's
some pollen coming out here.
I am very drawn by the detail, just
like anyone. It really gets me. But for
making an image for art, I try to actually
make them into landscapes. You know, I'll be
searching. I try to get something sort of with the
foreground, middle ground, background. I really
want sort of the illusion of the landscape this
landscape is like maybe half a centimeter across.
My specialty is light microscopy, so to
kind of give you orientation...so this is a
this is a commercial, what we call turnkey
confocal microscope. So it has a research
grade with inverted fluorescence microscope
down at the bottom and attached to that has
a confocal scan head. And then on the floor that
you can't see is a box that has a bunch of lasers
that allow us to excite the fluorescence
in our specimens. So what we are looking at
is pollen that I gathered from the rhododendron
bush out front. So as I mentioned, so the confocal
microscope is quite a sophisticated instrument.
In this situation, we have control over what
parts of the microscope are being used, what
colors of light we use to illuminate the sample,
as well as what colors of light we are detecting,
right? And those are going to be specific to the
fluorescent molecules that we are working with.
So here we have like a pile of these pollen grains
and we're imaging this with a 20x objective. This
entire field of view represents 320 micrometers,
so one third of a millimeter, right. So
this is probably close to 200x resolution.
So as I adjust the focus of the microscope,
so we're moving the objective lens relative
to the sample, we can start to see that there's
a very specific structure to these pollen grains,
right? Some of them have kind of a circle, some
of them have this kind of triangular shape right,
and so we can see here right so this guy in
the middle is probably kind of dehydrated
because he's really small, right? This guy has
a nice round one and then these are deflated.
I'm not a plant biologist so I don't know
exactly what that means. But right, we can adjust
how much light we put into the system. So
if we illuminate with lower intensity light
we get a darker image and so in this case the
blue color is coming from the software. So the
detector is a black and white detector, so as far
as the computer sees. This is a digital image,
it is a matrix of numbers, right. And then the
computer is really nice and gives it an intensity
so that our brain can then interpret this
pattern right. Another thing that's really
I really like about using the microscope is that
understanding the physiology of sight and the
neuroscience of sight and pattern recognition
influences your understanding of what you see.
So we can set up the microscope to generate
a three-dimensional data set, so it can take
a single image and then adjust the focus a very
specific amount and kind of step up through the
sample. So this is one I took ahead of time and
then we can actually visualize these structures
in three dimensions that we can try to understand
how different structures--right so in this case
we can move this guy sideways--we can try to
understand how different structures are organized
relative to each other in three-dimensional space.
Perspective is really valuable for interpretation.